hallo leute hier ist wieder eure mal
wanne und ich regiere heute auf ein
video von david hain der auf apa/red
reagiert der auf ein grünes messer
reagiert los geht's hallo meine lieben
freunde hier ist wieder einnehmen
trocken am start an die dass die kamera
euro halbiert trockenstress einem
bildschirm reingeguckt wir hatten alltag
ab sparten was ist eigentlich gerade der
trend in youtube deutsche lag natürlich
man reagiert jetzt einfach genau du
guckst die sachen an youtube ist jetzt
unter null angekommen jetzt mariane nur
scheiße oder müll jetzt machst du
einfach gar nichts und guckst genannt
aber zu ich habe es verbessert die bahn
nichts ein scheißland den reite ich auf
jeden fall mit weil wie hält man also
bist einfach du brauchst die klicks und
dass meine jetzt zu weihnachten einst
dass ich meiner mutter auch wieder
staucht er was seine mutter schenkt ganz
ehrlich ich werde mir einfach mal im
video rauspicken und darauf dann
reagieren damit das viral georg aber ich
wäre ja nicht euer behind selm
eindringlich den guide zum trick drauf
hätte ich schaue mir nicht die viralen
videos an sondern ich gucke mir einfach
einen von denen an die darauf reagieren
das ist david heinz dringe der junge her
der guckt sich ein messer video an habe
ich mir dachte schaue ihm doch einfach
mal dabei zu kollegen mal los david
sieht richtig über gelaunt aus alter der
hat richtig schlechte laune
der ist fertig danke dass ihr mir hat
dem link zu dem original video habe ich
euch auf jeden fall wie die beschreibung
gemacht weil ihr habt jetzt schon
gesehen hey das ist das video verlegen
dieses video auf weil ihr wisst bescheid
die hand braucht das geld denn ich muss
mir dieses jahr noch ein paar sachen
kaufen sonntag nicht vergessen um 18.30
ja dass hier sind all die schlepper die
ich mir letztes jahr 2016 gekauft habe
von eurem geld und die werde ich schön
kamera halten damit immer seht wie
sieht's aus und kriegt man eigentlich in
so ein video rein und sie werden dann
trotzdem gekriegt sagt dafür auf jeden
fall nach europa scheint auf jeden fall
auch eurem wellensittich habe ich nur
das ist ganz besonders wichtig eurem
gehirn gehoben damit ihr euch ab holt
das ist jedes mal raus neuer wir sagen
willst knights am start ich gehe raus
und er schließlich ich glaube ich glaube
das war sozialkritik ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher aber ich glaube er wollte
ein bisschen kritisch damit seien wegen
apparats video ich ja ich glaube war dem
hat es überhaupt nicht gefallen er leute
ich hoffe euch hat das video gefallen
und wenn ja dann gibt mir doch einen
daumen nach oben
und ich würde sagen ich verlose nächste
woche
den glitzernden scheißhaufen gewinne
gewinne gewinne schreibt jetzt hier
einen kommentar sonst ist die gewinn
chance nicht so groß und du musst einen
kanal abonnieren
ja das ist so tschüss